[SPEAKER_00]: Hang it in there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: How are you?
[SPEAKER_00]: You need me to put it in there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'll just slide it in.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know that I've seen you before.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm gonna need to see some ID.
[SPEAKER_04]: You need to see some ID?
[SPEAKER_00]: How are you?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm good.
How are you?
Come on through.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here we go.
Yeah, we can't go in yet.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know how you got in.
[SPEAKER_00]: What did you guys get to?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a different church.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is last week.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I called him and I said, how are you?
[SPEAKER_04]: And he said, oh, man, we're exhausted.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I said, me too.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he said, okay, I'll see you next week.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then I stood there and all the kids came to see us and they were like, can we do it one more time today?
[SPEAKER_04]: And I said, sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: We'll get back to you.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: How do you make this door not lock?
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a button.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: This one?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's just the deadbolt.
[SPEAKER_00]: It keeps locked.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, this one?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: It might be like on the home page or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I've got enough for a day or two.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Somebody told me the nine inches of rain goes from the average.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not in my area.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that where you're at?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, when everybody else is getting an inch, I'm getting like a tenth.
[SPEAKER_02]: Send that my way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Huh?
[SPEAKER_02]: You say all these people want to put up A's.
[SPEAKER_02]: He tells you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're trying to have that as much as we can.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, the bridge is coming.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America, and to the republic for which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
[SPEAKER_07]: Let's pray.
[SPEAKER_07]: Dear God, we come before you today grateful for the blessings you have given our county and the people who call it home.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you for the opportunities to serve and the many individuals who work each day to make our community a better place.
[SPEAKER_07]: As this meeting begins, help each person here approach their responsibilities with humility, fairness, and a spirit of cooperation.
[SPEAKER_07]: May conversations be thoughtful, decisions be made with care, and every action reflect a genuine desire to serve the citizens who have placed their trust in local government.
[SPEAKER_07]: We ask your hand in protection and safety over this county.
[SPEAKER_07]: Watch over our county, our employees, our first responders, our schools, our farmers, our businesses, and every family throughout our community.
[SPEAKER_07]: Strengthen those facing challenges, celebrate those experiencing success, and remind us all of the value of serving one another.
[SPEAKER_07]: Guide us in the work before us today.
[SPEAKER_07]: In your name we pray.
[SPEAKER_05]: Amen.
[SPEAKER_05]: Are you open to comments from the public?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd like to talk about the condition of 84th Street between South Point Drive and West Highway 210.
[SPEAKER_01]: When I moved there in 99, the area from 210 up to Dwight McMullen's house just passed it a little bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: chip and seal.
[SPEAKER_01]: And over the years, it's degraded.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're down to gravel, lime waste, or screenings on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we have a terrible time with the dust due to the tractor.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have, there's 21 residences that I know of in that portion of the street.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we have a housing issue.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the dust...
[SPEAKER_01]: Not today, but when it's dry, it is pretty unbearable because the houses are on the north side or south side.
[SPEAKER_01]: When the prevailing wind, one gets it or the other gets it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I was coming to you to see if we could get some improvements.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've had a petition, a polia that lives on our street.
[SPEAKER_01]: went around to all the residences.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have 18 signed up, and she can give you the petition whenever we're done.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had a question that I brought to the commission, not this commission, but previous commissions, about what the original intent was for maintaining the road, whether the original developer paid for the improvement for the chip and seal, and then the county takeover, which is what I presented.
[SPEAKER_01]: and whether it was supposed to be maintained as a chipped seal road or even better.
[SPEAKER_01]: So another problem we have with traffic is on South Point Road and Brady Creek Road, people live in the immediate area, use that to go to West Highway 210.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another problem we have that talked about using light does prevent it on the road, but I don't know how much it costs, but every time we have a heavy rain, the gravel washes down the road, you know, into the main surface and washes it off because the ditches are non-existent in some areas.
[SPEAKER_01]: And
[SPEAKER_01]: We've had problems with the intersection of 210 and West Highway, 210 and 84th Street.
[SPEAKER_01]: The asphalt is breaking off and there's potholes there and the county maintainer, he can't get out on the highway to fill in the potholes and the state doesn't seem to want to take care of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that portion of road there is a state right of way up to the first house.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I know the county or whoever, is it special road district or is it the county that takes care of that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you know?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think that maybe county, but without looking at the map, I can't tell you for sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it gets bladed, but I'd say the ditches going around that curve as you come off 210, the ditches aren't working, and the water runs across the road and washes all the gravel off into the ditches.
[SPEAKER_01]: And before you could do any serious work there as far as, like,
[SPEAKER_01]: It does prevent it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You almost need to work on the ditches because if you have to maintain the road and blade it a lot, you're gonna have to reapply that stuff, I presume.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not gonna put word in on that.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what we got going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've had some issues in the past that on T Highway, when the Rollins Creek Bridge was
[SPEAKER_01]: closed and the Pemper Creek Bridge was closed.
[SPEAKER_01]: They had to reroute traffic.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, farmers hauling grain to Kansas City would have to go down 84th Street and that beat up the road pretty bad a few years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's in a little better shape than it was before, but
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if this county got any compensation for wear and tear on that road or not, but I doubt it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's been beat up pretty hard in the past.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know paving is expensive, but
[SPEAKER_01]: From what I've heard, you don't like chip and seal anymore, and I don't know if it does prevent it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It would work very long, but, you know, the rains have come.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not, it's a hilly street in sections, and I think we have problems keeping it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want that petition now or after the meeting?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, we can't.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's really all I have.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you need more than one?
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you for listening.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kurt Croy, a couple follow-ups from last week.
[SPEAKER_00]: So Sheila was talking about a building that was insured for $977,000 that she thought should only be insured for $97,000.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did you guys figure out what that was?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's replacement cost.
[SPEAKER_00]: Was it $977,000?
[SPEAKER_00]: $977,000.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: The other one was he said he was going to look into the process about I was mentioned about I had to come in on March 11th and then the issue was tabled and not brought up again until the 16th of April and he said he was going to look into that process.
[SPEAKER_00]: The other one was about
[SPEAKER_00]: of the road tool that you guys got, did you get that, is that in use now?
[SPEAKER_00]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Did they get it fixed or whatever you said?
[SPEAKER_00]: It was like there was an issue with the hydraulics or something like that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that was it, actually.
[SPEAKER_07]: I guess I do have a quick question.
[SPEAKER_07]: Do we have any ARCA funds left?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'd have to ask to be sure, but I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that looks good.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yep, that's right.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys been getting plenty of rain?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's crazy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Seems like we can get in a ton of rain.
[SPEAKER_02]: North central.
[SPEAKER_06]: and tornadoes and you know a lot of our groups are up north west region county action county everyone's just getting hammered yeah it's absolutely crazy i know i just meet with the commission at grundy and philip ray was telling me that some of the bridges you can kind of wash it out they've got to do a bunch of work just a couple of bridges so yeah
[SPEAKER_06]: Not good.
[SPEAKER_06]: I've been getting too much rain, and every other year I've been in it, and they're like, well, we should get some rain.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's a drought, you know.
[SPEAKER_06]: It all comes at once.
[SPEAKER_06]: We used to get our property made, and we're not doing that anymore.
[SPEAKER_06]: We're trying to build it up.
[SPEAKER_06]: We do a lot of deer hunting, so we're just trying to let it kind of grow up.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's what a lot of the conservation agencies, you know, it's the best deer hunting farm in the farm that hasn't been touched in 10 years.
[SPEAKER_06]: So that's kind of what we're shooting for, just let it grow, and it'll be what it'll be.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's not a big plumbing state either, so...
[SPEAKER_06]: Happy, how have you been?
[SPEAKER_06]: Good?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, been doing good.
[SPEAKER_06]: Me and my, she's my fiancee now, we got engaged like four weeks ago, so that was really cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: Went on a trip to Colorado, just like a, it was Memorial Day weekend, so it was a four day weekend, so we went up there and hiked up this mountain, and I proposed to her up on top of the
[SPEAKER_06]: And then Sarah, on Saturday, she had her baby.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was a baby boy, and so everyone tells me she tried to do a home birth, which was kind of, you know, you don't hear about that very often, but she tried to go for that one, had a midwife, and she was in labor for like three days, and the baby wouldn't come out, so they ended up going to the hospital and living up there, but...
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, she said it was super painful, I guess.
[SPEAKER_06]: You know, I can't imagine.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, pretty exciting.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not excited that she's going to be off for five or six weeks now, but she kind of makes the whole thing run.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, I make a motion to be accepted in from MTS for the handouts for the class of 2020.
Thank you.
Amen.
[SPEAKER_07]: Amen.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is there any big time for 4th of July?
Are you ready to go?
Ready?
[SPEAKER_06]: And it doesn't show who's had claims and what they spent it on.
[SPEAKER_05]: It just kind of shows what we spent it on.
[SPEAKER_05]: Medical.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll show you.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, and so I know that we've pressed out here as well, but there is a lot of information.
[SPEAKER_06]: On the left there, on the very left column, you'll see the month, so it's just January through June.
[SPEAKER_06]: Obviously, we're not all the way through June yet, but there's more or less plenty of text so far in June.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then we have...
[SPEAKER_06]: We've had 20 employee only, one employee child.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then it kind of varies between different months on what the actual enrollments are.
[SPEAKER_06]: We have the aggregate fund deposit, and that's what we're actually paying into the claims account each month.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's the money that goes in for the money that comes out and that actually gets spent by our health plan.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's an aggregate fund deposit year to date, so it talks about what we fund at $56,000 into that account.
[SPEAKER_06]: If we look at RS claims paid and medical claims paid, you can kind of total those up, and that'll be to the very right.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's the gross paid claims year to date.
[SPEAKER_06]: And so we've spent $30,000.
[SPEAKER_06]: We've paid the $56,000.
[SPEAKER_06]: We are operating in the green to where years past, we have not been operating in the green this far into the year.
[SPEAKER_06]: We kind of got upside down right off the bat the last few years.
[SPEAKER_06]: So this is great news.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not to say we couldn't have a claim that could upset the apple cart, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Medical claims can
[SPEAKER_06]: and range hundreds of thousands of dollars.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we'll keep our fingers crossed that we don't have any large claims, but
[SPEAKER_06]: This is the best we've done in years past.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I'm really excited to kind of bring this in.
[SPEAKER_06]: We're at 53.7% of our attachment point, which is we fund at 125% of what we can actually spend.
[SPEAKER_06]: We're actually overfunded.
[SPEAKER_06]: If the claims exceed what we pay in, it's covered by stop loss or reinsurance, as you guys know, in years past.
[SPEAKER_06]: We've spent a couple of times what we've actually paid in, so two or three times.
[SPEAKER_06]: And we haven't owed anything extra.
[SPEAKER_06]: And that's kind of the benefit behind one of these policies is
[SPEAKER_06]: It operates just like a fully insured model.
[SPEAKER_06]: You pay your premiums, you're not responsible if you pay.
[SPEAKER_06]: You spend more than what we pay in.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we are fully insured more or less in this insurance plan.
[SPEAKER_06]: And like I said, I think employee satisfaction's been good.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know if it's been as high this year.
[SPEAKER_06]: I've got a couple things that we've been working on.
[SPEAKER_06]: The care navigation hasn't been as seamless as it's been in years past.
[SPEAKER_06]: So that's kind of what I'm on site today.
[SPEAKER_06]: I want to talk with employees about
[SPEAKER_06]: care navigation, where do you go if you need to see preferred providers?
[SPEAKER_06]: We are going to be switching the high-cost drug sourcing mechanism.
[SPEAKER_06]: We've been having, you know, I think there's been some changes in the prescription landscape over the past couple years.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's things like Trump Rx, there's Mark Cuban's Cost Plus.
[SPEAKER_06]: So there's a lot of people that are coming out with these new sourcing mechanisms for the really high-cost drugs.
[SPEAKER_06]: And so we're always on top of that.
[SPEAKER_06]: We're always in these meetings and these meetings
[SPEAKER_06]: seminars, learning about the most effective way to obtain these really high cost drugs.
[SPEAKER_06]: And what we're doing right now is with EHEM, which is our pharmacy benefit manager.
[SPEAKER_06]: They have been doing a great job.
[SPEAKER_06]: And so we saw that kind of right off the bat.
[SPEAKER_06]: We're taking action.
[SPEAKER_06]: And so we're kind of switching up our sourcing mechanism mid-year.
[SPEAKER_06]: There were a couple reasons why we switched from script sourcing in the first place.
[SPEAKER_06]: They were no longer going to be sourcing GLP-1s, and that's a large percentage of what we're actually using the sourcing mechanism for.
[SPEAKER_06]: We have people who are diabetic, and they need to get these GLP-1s, you know, the Ozymex, the Waco, these.
[SPEAKER_06]: We need the members to have those drugs to control their A1C, and we weren't going to be able to obtain those anymore.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we're now switching to a new model where we're going to be able to obtain those same drugs.
[SPEAKER_06]: They're not going to, no.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, they won't have to change anything.
[SPEAKER_06]: And we'll be doing outreach to those members who have been sourcing medications.
[SPEAKER_06]: And we're going to get them enrolled in the new program.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it'll be pretty seamless as far as from the employee's viewpoint.
[SPEAKER_06]: But on the back end, it's going to save the plan money.
[SPEAKER_02]: so we can't source.
[SPEAKER_06]: Exactly, exactly.
[SPEAKER_06]: And so that's kind of one of the reasons we're visiting today.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then also we just come in kind of quarterly and go over the claims data with you guys and make sure you guys are in the know as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: You know, we've always kind of preached this.
[SPEAKER_06]: If you don't have a receipt, and it's like anything the county does, you guys go get a new road and bridge, you know, you get an integrated, you know, every single bell and whistle that's on that thing from the bottom, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: You get an itemized receipt.
[SPEAKER_06]: Healthcare is one of the things that you typically don't get an itemized receipt for.
[SPEAKER_06]: They're just like, well, you spent more than you paid in, and, you know, we're doing this big business here.
[SPEAKER_06]: We try to be as accountable as possible.
[SPEAKER_06]: Obviously, I can't go over the PHI, the protective health information with you guys and say,
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, well, John got his knee replaced this year.
[SPEAKER_06]: He's the one spending all the money, you know.
[SPEAKER_06]: But this is kind of a, you know, it's a good snapshot of how the plan is performing.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I think it's just good to be accountable with you guys.
[SPEAKER_06]: i appreciate your guys's time that's all i have for you guys so if you guys have questions happy to answer them other than that i'm i gotta run to my car grab my business cards because i didn't bring my backpack in today uh i'll grab business cards pop around all the different departments make sure everyone's taken care of and kind of go from there all right thank you johnny okay awesome i've got one extra copy if you guys want i can leave it for sheila or
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thanks again, guys.
[SPEAKER_06]: You guys have a great day.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sometime last week or over the weekend during the last storm, lightning apparently struck the courthouse and it's damaged some of the transmission lines from United Fiber.
[SPEAKER_02]: Some of the phones are out, some of the computers haven't been working.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have our IT specialist on contact with our IT company out of Springfield.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're working on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So at this point, there's been some progress.
[SPEAKER_02]: The collector's office is back up and running.
[SPEAKER_02]: Planning and zoning, it does not have phones or computers.
[SPEAKER_02]: The assessor's office is having issues with computers and phones.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're continuing to work on that.
[SPEAKER_02]: The IT specialist will be back up here after 11.
[SPEAKER_02]: As I understand it,
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's just a work in progress to figure out all of the things that have been damaged.
[SPEAKER_02]: Even one string of lights on the top of the courthouse is out.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's just really weird stuff just here and there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not everything, but pieces in certain offices.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we're looking for the answer and trying to figure out how to fix it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you.
Thank you.